beaucoup de développement ce soir en ce
moment même dans la crise ukrainienne
tout s'accélère l'otan est en train de
tenir une conférence de presse pour
rendre une réponse officielle à moscou
même chose du côté des états unis on en
parle avec notre reporter guillemin
rossi bonsoir guillemin quelles sont les
informations que vous détenez on sait
que washington refuse d'exclure une
adhésion de l'ukraine à l'otan yum un
oui bonsoir stéphanie oui c'est tout à
fait cela les états unis ont refusé
d'accéder aux exigences de la russie sur
le nom élargissement de l'otan et
l'intégration et la non-intégration de
l'ukraine ainsi que sur le retrait des
troupes de l'alliance atlantique
d'europe de l'est c'est ce que demande
moscou depuis des mois maintenant et qui
semble être un prérequis à toute avancée
sur sa crise ukrainienne et puis il y a
eu d'autres sources de nouvelles
tensions vous en avez rapidement parler
la vice secrétaire d'état américaine
wendy sherman qui a déclaré aujourd'hui
que tout indiqué je cite que la russie
allait faire usage de la force
probablement d'ici trois semaines et
l'ambassade américaine à kiev a exhorté
ses ressortissants à quitter le pays
parallèlement six avions de combat
américains sont arrivés aujourd'hui en
estonie pour renverser renforcer la
mission de l'otan dans ce pays je le
rappelle frontaliers de la russie et
c'est sans compter sans ses 4000 obus
d'artillerie que va envoyer à kiev la
république tchèque
des éléments donc inquiétant à la porte
des négociations et elles totalement
fermées à l'heure où l'on parle en
alors peut-être pas totalement encore
stéphanie parce que d'un autre côté vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure anthony
blinken a déclaré qu'il était disposé à
rencontrer son homologue russe sergueï
lavrov et qu'il offrait je cite une voie
diplomatique sérieuse si la russie le
désirez et c'est sans compter les
européens l'europe qui veut elle
continuait à négocier preuve en est
cette réunion aujourd'hui à l'elysée au
format normandie c'est à dire entre
russes et ukrainiens m allemands et
français pardon pour discuter du dombass
réunion qui s'est terminée il y à peu il
ya peu après huit heures de négociations
on espère que cela augure des avancées
diplomatiques
merci guillemard aussi de ces précisions